>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Carlos Lozada: It
is my enormous pleasure
to give you Matthew Desmond.
[ Applause ]
>> Matthew Desmond: All right.
Hey. Hi. How are you?
Oh my goodness.
It's so good to be here.
Oh, Carlos.
I've never met Carlos
but I feel like I've --
you know, he's been in
my life for the last year
and I remember reading your review.
I remember the exact place
I was when I read it.
I read it on my phone.
It was at a faculty thing and my
editor was sitting right next to me.
And it came in and we were just
looking at it and we were amazed
and you know, book critics
have an incredibly hard
and often thankless job.
But you know, for kind of
authors like me who have like,
written other books but they've
been for an academic audience
that are trying to
break out somewhere --
general audience, you
know and you know,
a critic that really does
her job or his job right
so thank you so much Carlos.
Not only for pushing this
book but for, you know,
your amazing work at the post.
And it's just good to be
with all of you today.
I donated, I got the sticker.
If you donate you get a sticker.
You didn't mention that.
You get a sticker so
I got one, do it.
So, we should just get into it.
So, we live in a weird country.
We are the richest democracy
with the worst poverty.
That's who we are.
And there's no other advanced
industrial society that has the kind
of poverty that we do or the
depths of poverty that we have
and that's always troubled me.
And I know it's troubled
a lot of you and I wanted
to understand the role that
housing plays in that story.
And so I thought that
looking at eviction,
looking at families
forcibly, physically removed
from their homes was a decent
way of going about that.
So, I started this work
the old -fashioned way.
I moved into a trailer park
on the far south side
of Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
Milwaukee's a city in America.
It's in the middle of the country.
It's our 30th most popular city.
Anyone from Milwaukee?
Any Milwaukee in the house?
Over here?
Love you guys.
Can't make stuff up now, though.
So I moved into a trailer park
in the south side of the city
and I lived there for
about five months.
And then I moved into a roomy
house on the north of the city.
That's Milwaukee's inner city.
And I lived there about 10 months
and form those neighborhoods I
followed families getting evicted.
And I went everywhere
with those families.
I went to eviction court with them,
followed them into shelters
and abandoned homes.
I watched their kids, I slept on
their floor, I ate off their table,
I went to work with them,
church, AA meetings with them.
Several funerals, I was
even there for a birth.
Like there for birth.
Carlos, have you been to a birth?
Yeah. I know right, I know, yeah.
It's intense.
So, I try to get to know these
families as much as I could
but I knew to really understand how
the low-income housing market works,
I needed to get as just as tight
with the landlords doing
the evicting as I did
with the families getting
evicted and so I did.
And so I went to eviction court with
landlords too and I helped them pass
that eviction notices
and collect rents.
I saw them buy and sell properties.
I understand why you would
buy properties in some
of the poorest neighborhoods
in the city.
I understand a little but
more what makes landlords tick
and what ticks them off.
And I try to write a book about
this incredibly complicated
but central relationship when it
comes to understanding inequality
in America today, that
between landlords and tenants.
So, I was going about this work
and there are these questions
that kept springing to mind like
"How often does eviction happen?
Who gets evicted?
What are the long-term consequences
of getting tossed from your home?"
But I went looking for some study
release and data that would allow me
to address those questions
but I just came up empty.
And so I said, "Okay, I need a --
I needed to do some things
to collect today to myself."
And one thing that we
did was designed a survey
because Milwaukee area renter study.
We talked to about 1,100 people
all over the city of Milwaukee.
And we send interviews into some
of the most distressed
neighborhoods in the city.
Those red dots and some of the
most affluent neighborhoods
in the city, those blue dots.
I had an interviewer mugged.
One was bitten by a dog.
That's actually the same guy, Steve.
Steve needs to work on
his situational awareness.
But you know, we worked
really hard for this data.
We got an 84 percent response rate
which in nerd land
is like really good.
And we asked families like
250 questions about their kids
and their housing and their health
and their experience with eviction.
I didn't stop there.
We analyzed hundreds of
thousands of evictions records
that went through the civil court.
We talked to 250 people right after
they're evicted because we wanted
to know "Why do you get evicted
but you don't even though you
owe your landlord the exact
same amount?"
Analyzing millions of 911 calls,
hundreds of nuisance ordinances
and I try to put that big data into
conversation with the smaller data.
My notebooks.
Like the things that I was
learning on the ground every day.
Just living alongside tenants
and working alongside landlords.
And Evicted in that spirit is really
a book that starts on the ground
and it ends on the ground.
It follows eight families
through the process of eviction.
You know, you meet Scott.
Scott's in the book, you know,
Scott was this kind of nurse
that got hooked on pain killers and
developed an addiction to heroin.
And you kind of see him wrestle with
that addiction throughout the book.
Vanetta's in the book.
You know, Vanetta's a single mom
trying to raise three young kids.
She's working an old country buffet
and her hours got cut and she was
so terrified of losing her
home and maybe her kids
to child protected services
that she committed armed robbery
to pay the rent.
This is someone without
any criminal record.
And in that spirit, in the spirit
of letting the folks that are
on the front edge of this problem
be our biggest teachers, you know,
I want to share with you
one person's story today
and that's Arlene's story.
So Arlene had a 14 year old son,
Jory, and one day he was cutting
up throwing snowballs at passing
cars and he smacked this car.
And it was like -- and
this man jumped out.
So, Jory and his cousin
like hightailed it inside
and they locked -- and he locked the
door but the man followed them there
and he kicked the door in.
he kicked the door down.
And thank God he left before
anything else happened
but when Arlene's landlord
found out about that she decided
to evict Arlene and her
boy for damaging property.
So Arlene took her two sons,
Story and Jafaris, who was six,
to the salvation army
homeless shelter.
Which everyone in Milwaukee
just calls the lodge
so you can tell your kids, "We're
staying at the lodge tonight."
Like it's a hotel.
And from there they're on the
hunt for another place to live
and they found one on 19th street
but there was often no water
and Jory had to bucket out
what was in the toilet.
Arlene told me, "You know,
it was 525 for a whole house
and it was quiet and it
was my favorite place."
When we looked in that survey and
we asked what happens to families
after they're evicted, one big
thing we found is that they move
into much worse housing
than they lived in before.
So, if he want to know why
some kids live with lead paint,
and exposed wires,
no heat, no water,
one reason is their families
are forced to accept those kinds
of conditions in the harried
aftermath of an eviction.
So, the city eventually found
Arlene's favorite place unfit
for human habitation.
They boarded up the windows and the
doors and Arlene and her boys were
on the hunt for another
place to live.
And she told Story like, "We
take whatever we can get."
Which is what moving looks
like at the very bottom.
Just like taking what you could get.
And what Arlene could get is
this drab apartment complex
on Atkinson avenue but she
soon feared for her boys
because she learned it was
like a haven for drug dealers.
In face the whole block
was drug soaked and hot.
And she feared for Story
because he was goofy
and had this beautiful smile
and would talk to anyone.
So, in Arlene's case, why she
moved, the fact that she was forced
out of this place was really
important for why she ended
up in such a bad neighborhood.
And we thought, "Can we
test that statistically?"
And we did and we found that
you can control for a lot
of different things and
you still see the families
who get evicted move from poor
neighborhoods to even poorer ones,
from dangerous neighborhoods
to blocks
with even higher level of crime.
Eviction pushes families
deeper into disadvantage.
So Arlene moved out of
Atkinson as fast as she could.
She found this two
bedroom bottom muted duplex
on 13th street and Keefe.
There's a big ol' hole in
the living room window.
There wasn't like a lock
so Arlene had to lock it
with like a plank she
slit into brackets.
The cargo was just filthy and ground
in but she put on a good face.
You know, she hung up curtains
and she took a piece of clothing
and she stuffed it in
that whole in the window.
So, the rent for this kind
of place, which was located
in a really poor neighborhood
in Milwaukee,
which is our fourth poorest
city, was 550 dollars a month,
utilities not included
which consumed 88 percent
of Arlene's welfare check.
And she knew that some
months she would have
to sell her food stamps
to make rent.
And her and the boys would try
to get by on oodles and noodles.
You know, when you're paying over
80 percent of your income on rent,
there's no extra money for anything.
Like no money for clothes
for Jory or toys for Jafaris.
Jafaris had this like amazing
ability to transform like a bucket
or a bottle or a dog leash
whatever he could get his hands on.
And the soldiers and tanks,
you know, engaged in warfare.
So, here's the situation,
you know, Arlene is not alone
in spending the vast majority
of her income on housing.
For about 100 years there's
been a consensus in America
that we should spend
about 30 percent
of our income on housing costs.
That gives us enough money to save,
afford enough food, transportation
but that is so far
off in the realities
of most renting families today.
So, clicker, clicker.
I see the light going on.
We have pros on it.
Are we --
I can go on.
It's okay.
I'm not like PowerPoint addicted.
But kind of.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to on and I'm
going to let the pros handle.
So, for the past 20
years the percentage
of poor renting families spending
30 percent of their income or less
on housing, our widespread standard
of affordability has gone
down and down and down.
But the percentage of poor renting
families spending at least half
of their income on housing has
gone up and up and up to the point
that today the majority
of poor renting families are
spending half their income
on housing costs and about one in
four of those families are spending
over 70 percent of their income
just on rent and utilities.
So, just imagine that, 70 percent
of your income is just like gone
in the beginning of the month.
If you want a roof over
your head or hot water
under those condition you don't
need to make a huge mistake
or have a big emergency wash over
your life to invite to evictions.
Something as innocent
as snowball can do it.
So, for people like Arlene,
eviction is much more the result
of inevitability than
personal irresponsibility.
So, how do we get to this place?
So, there's three ingredients
to this recipe.
One is the one we talk about a lot,
which is for the past two decades,
really the past four,
the incomes of Americans
of modest means have been plat.
In some areas of the country
they've fallen in real terms.
But as families are watching
their housing costs flat line
or their incomes flat line,
their housing costs were soaring.
Between 1995 and today the median
rent in this country adjusting
for inflation has increased
by over 70 percent.
Cost of fuel and utilities have
increased by 52 percent since 2000.
And so, you have this like gap
between what low income families
are bringing in and what they have
to pay for basic shelter needs.
So, then we might ask, and
this is the third ingredient,
well, where's public housing?
Or housing assistance of any kind?
And the answer is it's there but
it's only for the lucky minority
of families that receive it today.
So, only about six percent
of poor families that live
in public housing today, that's
that little blue part of the pie,
12 percent receive a
rent reducing voucher,
which used to be called
section eight vouchers.
But the unlucky majority, the
remaining 75 percent receive --
what's the technical term.
Nothing. Nada, Zippo from state,
local or federal governments.
You know, I think that's
be a situation
that would be utterly
unthinkable when it comes
to meaning other basic needs.
Imagine if we turned away
three and four families
that apply for food stamps.
Like, "I'm sorry, we
don't have enough for you.
You have to go hungry."
But that's exactly how we treat
low income families searching
for affordable shelter today.
So, Arlene looked up looking for
housing assistance a long time ago.
One day on a whim she stopped by
the housing authority and asked
about the list and she was told
by the person behind the glass
like, "The list is frozen."
Because on it were 3,500
families who had applied
for rent assistance five years ago.
And that's not bad.
I mean, the waiting for
public housing in some
of our big cities has not counted
in years, it's counted in decades.
So, I have two young
children now and if I apply
for public housing today
in this city I would
probably be a grandfather
by the time my application
came up for review.
So, if Arlene wanted public housing
this is what she'd have to do.
She'd have to wait three or four
years before the list unfroze
and then she'd have to wait
another five or six year
until her name made it
to the top of the pile.
And then she'd just have to pray
that the person reviewing her
application would ignore all the
evictions she collected while trying
to make ends meet unassisted
in the private market.
When we think of the typical poor
family today, we shouldn't think
of them living in public
housing or getting any kind
of help from the government.
We should think of Arlene
because she's the average case.
So, on 13th street, Arlene found
this bucket of paint and rollers
and brushes in the basement and
she gave the walls a fresh coat
but not long after moving in
her sister died and she pitched
in some money for the funeral.
She didn't have the money
but no one else did either
and she gave out of love.
The next month she
missed an appointment
with her welfare case worker
because the letter announcing
the appointment was mailed
to 19th street or maybe
Atkinson Avenue.
And Arlene's case worker
tried sending in the computer
and Arlene's $620 a month check was
cut, we call it getting sanctioned,
and by that time she fell
two months behind on rent
and she got the pink papers.
So, Milwaukee is a city of
about 105,000 renter homes.
Every year in Milwaukee landlords
evict about 16,000 people.
That's about 40 people a
day evicted in Milwaukee.
We've know crunched the numbers
in Cleveland, in Kansas City,
in Chicago, we found rates
similar to Milwaukee's.
New York city you see 60 marshal
evictions every single day.
It's estimated that renters
in over 2.8 million homes
think they'll be evicted soon.
Now, the first time I crunched these
numbers I thought they're wrong
because they are so high.
They're wicked scary,
as we say in Boston.
But these numbers only count
formal court ordered evictions
and there are other ways,
cheaper and quicker ways
for a landlord to get you out.
So, Joe Prozinski, he was a
building manager in the inner city,
and he said, "You know, Matt,
for every eviction I do that goes
to the court, there are
like 10 that don't."
So, what Joe would do is say
like, "Look, Carlos, you know,
you're behind, man, and
I just I need my money.
I'll tell you what.
I'll give you $200 and I'll let you
use my van if you're out by Sunday."
So, if you got to get evicted,
that's not a bad eviction.
I met another landlord
that if you're behind,
he'll just take your door off.
There are a lot of ways to get a
family out and we worked really hard
in that survey to capture
all those informal eviction
that never go through the court.
And if you had those up with formal
evictions that are legally processed
and if you count things
like building condemnations,
like what happened to
Arlene's place on 19th street
and landlord foreclosures, you learn
that every two years in Milwaukee,
one in eight renters is
evicted, which is crazy.
One in eight.
Not one in eight single moms, not
one in eight folks in deep poverty,
just one in eight renters
every eight -- every two years.
And like poverty researchers
and journalists like me,
like for a long time we've
written sentences like this.
"Low income families exhibit high
rates of residential insecurity."
And we haven't said why and I
think what we're learning is
that poor folks are moving so
much because they're forced to.
And it's not just a
rhetorical point, you know,
we have a statistical model
that shows that if you control
for evictions, low income families
don't move more than anyone else,
which means if we want
more family stability
and we want more community
stability we need fewer evictions.
This is a problem that affects
the young and the old, the sick
and the able bodied, but the face
of our eviction epidemic
is just moms with kids.
Moms with kids, if you go
into any urban housing court
around the country you just see
like a ton of kids sitting there.
Until recently the south Bronx, it's
housing court had a daycare inside
of it because there were so many
kids coming through its stores.
And low income African American
women like Arlene and moms
in particular are evicted
at startlingly high rates.
Among Milwaukee renters, one
in five black women report
being evicted sometime
in their life compared
to one in 15 white women.
And I think that should trouble us.
I think that should
disturb us because it means
that eviction is something
like the feminine equivalent
to incarceration.
Now, we know that many of our poor,
young African American men are
being swept out by the long arm
of the criminal justice system.
They're being locked up.
Many of our poor African-American
women are being locked out
and they're disproportionately
bearing the brunt
of the eviction crisis.
This also isn't just a crisis that's
on the north side of Milwaukee
or the south side of Chicago.
This is in poor white communities
which I write about a lot
in my books and Latino
and immigrant communities.
It's in expensive cities like this
one and it's in inexpensive cities
like Milwaukee and
Baltimore and Huston.
One in five of all renters in
America now spends over 50 percent
of their income on housing.
So, Arlene went to eviction court
and as is court custom in Milwaukee,
she got to stay two extra
days in her apartment for each
of her two days, and those days came
and went and she was ordered to be
out on a day in early January.
My Milwaukee friends here will tell
you January is cold in Milwaukee
and this January was
especially cold.
The weather men had said it would
drop below 40 with the wind chill.
But if Arlene waited
any longer, you know,
the landlord would call the sheriff
and he would arrive within 10 days
with a judge's order and a
side arm and a team of movers
and they would have piled
everything on the side walk.
And they take everything, like
the meat cuts in the freezer,
the shower curtains, the bible,
the silk plants, Jarafis'
asthma machine.
And so, Arlene just struck out into
the cold and after a lot of calls,
you know, she finally found domestic
violence shelter room 30 minutes
away from Milwaukee.
She just lied about being abused
so she could get her boys a roof
and she was once again on the
hunt for another place to live.
So, she called on or applied
to 20 apartments, and then 40,
and then 60, and then 80.
I counted.
She was accepted to none of them.
Even in the inner city
many were out of reach.
And the place she could afford,
if she basically tossed
everything she had at the rent,
weren't calling back either.
And part of the reason, besides her
poverty, was her eviction record.
So, in Milwaukee your eviction is
published publicly online for anyone
to see and if it's not in your
city there are literally hundreds
of tenant screening
companies waiting
to sell landlords this information.
And this is a big deal to landlords.
You know, most land lords
that I spent time with said,
"We're not going to take
anyone with an eviction
within the last two or three years."
So, this mark, this
blemish of eviction
that follows families is the reason
they are forced into worse housing
and into worse neighborhoods
after they're evicted.
So finally at the 90th
landlord, Mr. 90 said yes.
He had a one-bedroom
apartment, it was $525.
Arlene didn't much consider,
like, the conditions of the place,
what the neighborhood was like.
"A house is a house,"
she told Story.
So two months after their eviction
court hearing, they moved in.
And Arlene liked it.
You know, all the lights worked,
all the cabinets had fixtures.
And when she and the boys had
unloaded a bunch of the stuff,
Arlene just like sat down
on the floor and she found
like a trash bag full of
towels and leaned against it.
And Story came over and, like,
pitched his 14-year-old head
into her shoulder, and Jafaris came
and like snuggled into her lap,
and they just stayed like
that for a long time.
So Arlene got her stuff
out of storage.
She hung pictures on the wall.
She hung a sign over the
sink to Story that said,
"If you do not clean
up after yourself,
we are going to have problems."
Do you guys remember
what it's like to 14?
Sucky and brutal.
And it's especially hard to be 14
and experience long
stretches of homelessness.
Between 7th and 8th grade, Story
went to five different schools.
And at his new school, he
started acting out a little bit,
and one day a teacher yelled at him.
And he got mad and he kicked
her in the shin and he ran home.
And the teacher called the principal
but then she thought it would be
appropriate to call the police,
and when officers visited Arlene
and her boys at the new apartment,
and the landlord found out about
that, he told her she had to go.
It's kids.
You know, kids are a
big part of this story.
They can prolong the time you're
homeless after your eviction,
and they sometimes are the
reason for your eviction.
In fact, when we look at that
survey that we did in housing court,
that survey where we
were trying understand,
"Why is it that you get
evicted but you don't,
even though you owe your
landlord the same thing?"
What we found was it wasn't
race, it wasn't gender,
it wasn't even how much you owed.
It was kids.
If you lived with children,
the chance of you getting
evicted tripled [inaudible].
What you're seeing in that
finding is landlord discretion.
You're seeing the landlord say,
"I'll work with you
but not with you."
Because, you know, like, kids, like,
use the curtains for superhero capes
and they flush toys down the toilet.
They cause some guy whose
car's just been smacked
with a snowball to
kick your door in.
They can test positive for lead
poisoning, draw the attention
of child protective
services, the police.
"Kids cause us headache," is
what one landlord told me.
Family discrimination is illegal,
but we know from studies that many
of us don't even recognize that
as a kind of discrimination.
So after that eviction, Arlene
started to unravel a little bit.
She told me, "It's like
I got a curse on me.
It won't stop for nothing.
Sometimes I feel my body
trembling or shaking.
I'm tired but I can't sleep.
I'm fixing to have
a nervous breakdown.
My body's trying to shut down."
I recently published a
study that show that moms
who get evicted experience higher
rates of depression two years later.
It sticks with you.
And we know that between
2005 and 2010,
years where housing costs were
soaring around our country,
something else was going up to
and those were suicides
attributed to eviction.
They doubled during
that five-year timespan.
Arlene told me, "Just
my soul is messed up.
I wish my life were different.
I wish that when I be an old lady,
I can sit back and look at my kids
and they be grown and
they, you know,
become something, something
more than me.
And we'll all be together
and be laughing.
We'll be remembering stuff like
this and be laughing at it."
The home is the center of life.
It's our refuge from work,
the pressures of school,
Minnesota streets.
We say at home, we're ourselves.
Everywhere else, we're someone else.
At home, we remove our masks.
In languages spoken
all over the world,
the word for home encompasses
not just shelter but warmth
and family, community, the womb.
The ancient Egyptian
hieroglyph for home,
it was the same one for mother.
So eviction causes loss.
Families lose not only their
homes, but often their schools,
their community, your stuff.
It takes a good amount of time
and money to establish a home.
An eviction can delete all that.
An eviction comes with this blemish,
which can cause you not to move
into a safe neighborhood
and to decent housing,
it can also prevent you from
moving into public housing,
because many of our
public housing authorities,
even though they don't have
to, count eviction as a blemish
or a strike against an application,
which means we're systematically
denying housing help
to families that need it most.
So we push those families into slum
housing and into bad neighborhoods.
We have a study that shows
that eviction causes job loss.
I don't know if any of y'all
in this room have been evicted,
but if you have, you know why.
It's such a consuming,
stressful, drawn-out event.
It can cause you to make mistakes
at work, lose your footing
in the labor market, and then
there's the effect that eviction has
on your soul, like
Arlene would put it.
Your mental health.
Now, I think when we add all
that up, we have to conclude
that evictions, which used
to be rare in this country,
which used to draw crowds, they're
not just a condition of poverty.
They're a cause of it too.
They're making things worse
and they're leaving a deep
and jagged scar on
the next generation,
which means we can't fix poverty
in America without fixing housing.
So how do we fix it?
So imagine if every family
in this country had a decent,
affordable place to leave.
If Arlene didn't have to give 80
percent of her income to rent,
she could keep her kids fed and
clothed and off the streets.
We know from previous research
that when families finally receive
a housing voucher after years
and years on the waiting list, when
they finally receive this ticket
that allows them to pay only 30
percent of their income on rent,
instead of 60 or 70, they
do one consistent thing
with their freed-up income.
They take it to the grocery store.
They buy more food and their kids
become stronger and less anemic.
And they work.
For the lucky minority
of poor families
that benefit from them today.
But the vast majority of our
pour families aren't so lucky,
and their kids, with names like Jori
and Jafar, aren't getting enough
to eat because the rent eats first.
And, like, if we can't afford the
freedoms our country offers us
without a roof over our
head, like basic stuff,
the freedom to better ourselves,
to protect our children,
to be part of a community, then
shouldn't access to a decent,
affordable home be part of what
it means to be an American?
>> Yes.
>> We've affirmed --
[ Applause ]
We've affirmed provision and old age
and access to 12 years of education
and basic nutrition to be rights
in this country because we believe
that human flourishing and vitality
are impossible without those things.
There is not an argument that says
that you can go without housing
and still flourish and
be economically mobile.
Housing should be a right in this
country and the reason is simple.
Without stable shelter,
everything else falls apart.
So then the question becomes, well,
how do we deliver on
that obligation?
And there's a lot of
good news here actually.
There's a lot of good news.
I mean, just a few generations
ago, there were slums in our cities
and babies were dying
of tuberculosis
and there were outhouses in the
middle of Philadelphia when some
of y'all were still alive.
We took on a battle with
the slum and we won.
We won. And I'll be
the first to admit,
and I think the book is pretty
clear out about this fact,
that we still have a long way to go.
When I lived in the trailer park,
I didn't have hot water for most
of the time, and I told the
landlord, like, "I am a writer.
I'm going to write about
you and your trailer park."
[ Laughter ]
So imagine what my
neighbors had to endure.
But there's no arguing that
we haven't made huge steps
in the right direction when
it comes to the quality
of housing folks are
living in today.
It's just an important
thing to recognize.
Because sometimes when you talk
about poverty, the problem can be --
fell so depressing and
feel so entrenched.
It can feel like, "We fought the
war on poverty and nothing works."
And that's just empirically false.
When we want to take on
big problems as a country,
we have come up with big solutions.
I also just take a lot of heart
that there's organizations all
around this country just putting in
work, driving down eviction rates,
preserving affordable housing,
fighting family homelessness.
So you can go to this website that
we've started called just shelter,
which amplifies that work, and
you can click on DC or Baltimore,
Virginia, wherever you call
home, and you can figure out,
"Who's working on this
problem in my own backyard?"
You can learn more about what it
looks like in your own community.
Maybe you can get plugged in
with your time or your money.
So what's the bigger picture?
A problem as big as the
affordable housing crisis calls
for a big solution.
We are bleeding out and it
would be disingenuous of me
to stand here before you and
say a band-aid fix will do it.
Because it won't.
We need real bold political
leadership here.
We need real moral vision here, so
one idea that would make a dream
of affordable housing, a dream of a
house for every American a reality,
would be to take a program
that we already have
that works pretty darn well, the
Affordable Housing Voucher Program,
and expand it to everyone
below the poverty line.
So the idea is super simple.
It's not even my idea.
You take this program, and if
you fall below the poverty line,
you qualify for it.
And you get a voucher and you
can live anywhere you want,
as long as your housing isn't
too expensive or too shoddy,
and instead of paying
60 or 70 percent
of your income on housing,
you pay 30.
The voucher covers the rest.
That would fundamentally change
the face of poverty in America.
That would make evictions
rare again.
That would drive down
family homelessness.
Families finally would receive that,
that you feel when you're only
paying 30 percent of your income
on housing, and be able to
buy enough food and save.
So there's two questions
here that we might ask.
One, would that be a
disincentive to work?
It's a fair question.
We in the research community
have spent a lot of time
on that question, and there
are some studies that show
that when families
receive housing assistance,
they also experience a slight
reduction in work hours.
I think they want to just
spend a little bit more time
with their kids.
There are way more studies that
don't find any relationship
between those two things.
Nerds like me call it
a null relationship.
And I think the status quo is a much
bigger threat to self-sufficiency
and work than any affordable
housing program could be.
I mean, families are crushed
by the high cost of housing.
They can't afford community
college classes or job training,
so they can get plugged in in
a better place in the economy.
A lot of them can't afford to stay
in one place long enough
to just hold down a job.
And just think of all, like, the
brainpower and talent and creativity
that we just squander because we ask
someone like Arlene to spend so much
of hers trying to figure out
how she's going to make rent
from one month to the next, or where
she's going to live after her kids
and her are inevitably,
predictably, evicted.
Poverty reduces people
born for better things.
Arlene didn't want some small life.
She didn't want to gain the
system and eek out an existence.
In fact, when she finally
found stable housing,
the first thing she did was
start applying for jobs.
She wanted to work and thrive
and contribute, and a stable,
affordable home would give
folks like Arlene a shot
at realizing their full potential.
So the second question
is, can we afford it?
It sounds kind of expensive, a
universal housing voucher program.
It's totally expensive.
We can totally afford it.
So Bipartisan Policy Center
crunched the numbers a few years ago
and they found that the kind
of program that I'm advocating
for today would cost us an
additional 22 billion dollars
a year.
22 billion dollars.
Raw number.
Doesn't account for the savings we'd
recoup by driving down homelessness,
rates of depression, rates of
asthma, things we already pay for,
because there's two ways to spend.
We can spend smart
or we spend stupid.
That's just the raw number.
Now, 22 billion dollars
is not a small figure,
but it's well within our capacity.
We have the money.
We just made decisions
about how to spend it.
So, every year in this country,
homeowner tax subsidies,
especially the mortgage
interest deduction, they far,
far outpace direct housing
assistance to the needy.
We already have a universal
housing program.
It's an entitlement.
It's just not for poor people.
So the year that Arlene was evicted
from 13th Street, we, as a nation,
spent about 41 billion dollars
on direct housing assistance
to the needy, things like
public housing in Section 8.
That same year, we spent
about 171 billion dollars
on homeowner tax subsidies.
That number, 171 billion
dollars, that was equivalent
to the entire budgets of the
Departments of Education,
Veteran Affairs, Homeland Security,
Justice and Agriculture, combined.
It's a rather large number.
Most of that benefit goes to
families with six-figure incomes,
because if your income is
bigger, your mortgage is bigger
so your deduction is too.
Most white families in America
own a home with a mortgage.
Most Latino and African-American
families do not.
It is hard to think
of a social policy
that more unblushingly amplifies
our racial and economic inequality
than our current housing
policy does.
So if we want to spend the bulk of
our public dollars on the affluent,
at least when it comes to housing,
let's just be honest about that.
Let's just own up to that.
Let's just be like, "Yes, this
is the kind of country you want.
This is our social contract."
Instead of repeating this
lie that the richest country
on the planet can't
afford to do more.
If poverty persists --
[ Applause ]
You know, if poverty
persists in America,
it's not because we lack resources.
We lack something else.
Okay. So it's one idea.
Like, let others come.
You know, one city has to
build, another has to destroy.
Our cities are different.
You know, what works in DC is
going to fail in Milwaukee.
LA needs a completely different
thing than Birmingham does.
But I think whatever our
way out of this mess,
one thing for me is certain.
Like, this degree of inequality
and this level of social suffering
and this just, like,
blunting of human potential,
this cold denial of,
like, a basic human need,
I don't -- like, this isn't us.
Like, this doesn't have to be us.
By no American value is
this situation justified.
There's no ethical code, there's
no holy teaching, there's no piece
of scripture that could be summoned
to defend what we've allowed
our country to become.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
We have time for questions.
Thanks, sound guys, for getting
through that technical difficulty.
It's really great to
see you guys up here.
Thank you so much.
>> Could you talk about how
you established relationships
that enabled you to be with the
renters and with the landlords?
>> Matthew Desmond: Yeah.
So I think living in the
community helped a lot.
I think, you know, Scott
and Lorraine and other folks
that I wrote about in the book were
my neighbors in the trailer park.
And the landlords were really keen
on just people understanding
their work.
You know, they were
proud of their work.
They often were, like,
self-starters, you know,
and built a kind of
business up from nothing
and they were interested in that.
That doesn't mean it was easy all
the time, and often, you know,
tenants would not tell me things.
They were afraid I'd
tell the landlord.
Sometimes the landlord
would do the same.
But I think just spending
enough time with folks
and really living there
helped do it, yeah.
>> This is a great book and I love
the combination of quantitative
and qualitative materials
that you brought together.
But I'd like to go back to
your last comments here.
Could you kind of recreate
the historical context
in which the original housing
voucher program came about?
And are those replicable
in the near future?
And it's not a negative question,
but just how did it come
about, first of all?
>> Matthew Desmond: Negative
questions are good too, you know?
Negative questions are good.
And so, but I don't see
it as a negative question.
That's a really important point.
So the story of public policy toward
housing is often a story riddled
with, like, really big mistakes,
or that's how it's read anyways.
So, you know, we had a giant, like,
social experiment called
public housing, which was going
to replace our sum communities.
And we said, "Why don't we
build giant towers in the middle
of really poor, desolate
areas of our city?
Pruitt-Igoe in St. Louis,
Robert Taylor homes in Chicago.
And so we built these towers up,
and the thing that we often
forget is, like, that was amazing.
Like, when you read the transcripts
of the first residents of those kind
of public housing towers, they
were like, "This is incredible.
This is like Christmas."
But we defunded it.
We gutted the funding and
soon, like, no one was picking
up the trash and the
elevators weren't working.
And if you were a family
that could move out, you did,
and those towers descended into
incredibly concentrated poverty
and sometimes even, like, chaos.
You know, Pruitt-Igoe, these
giant towers in St. Louis,
were destroyed 18 years
after they were erected.
So from those ashes, the Public
Housing Voucher System started
to emerge, and it has become the
main way we provide affordable
housing to families today.
It's not a perfect system, but
there's no study in the world
that shows that you can offer
families equal quality housing
for a lesser cost than you
can through a voucher program.
So the problem that I always
[inaudible] with when I was trying
to conclude this book,
like, what policy do I want
to get behind, is the
problem of scale.
There's all sorts of awesome
ways we can address this problem,
but if we want to address
it at scale,
the voucher program's
the best way to do so.
>> [Inaudible] question.
You made a distinction between
men who are incarcerated and women
who lose their homes, and I just
wanted to point out that the rate
of female incarceration is rising
exponentially in the US right now.
That aside, what could you
tell me about the landlords
that would surprise me, given my
sense that these are, you know,
bad people or something like
-- what would, you know,
something that would
make me feel differently?
>> Matthew Desmond: I hope
the book does its best to try
to capture both sides with
their full complexity,
and I think it's way too easy,
you know, just to say, "Oh,
these landlords are just greedy."
Or, "Oh, these tenants are just
lazy," depending on where we fall
in the political spectrum.
You know, from the sidewalk
view, it's really hard.
And so one thing that surprised
me was when I started this work,
I was like, "Why would you buy
property on 13th Street and Keefe?"
And when I finished this
work, I was like, "Oh,
why wouldn't you do that?"
Because you can make a lot of
money, quite a bit of money.
And so, you know, the landlord of
the trailer park that I lived in,
you know, he let me copy his
rent rolls, so I could account
for vacancies and missed payments.
I got his mortgage records,
I got his water bill,
I got his trash collecting
records, I got his eviction costs.
I'm telling you all this so
you believe me, that, you know,
the landlord of, like,
the worst trailer park
in the fourth worst
city of Milwaukee,
which is 130-trailers big,
takes home about 470,000
dollars a year after expenses.
That, for me, changed the
way I think about poverty,
because it means, like, poverty
isn't just about low incomes.
It's also about extractive markets.
You know, there are winners and
losers, and there are losers
because there are winners.
And that point isn't
just about landlords.
I think that point is about a
lot of us in the room today,
including things like our housing
and our schools and our tax records.
>> Hey, Matt.
Thank you for this
great, great book.
I wanted to say a quick question
about the writing of the book.
Why did you choose not to
include yourself in the book,
despite doing the same kind of
immersive journalism as a, say,
a Nickel and Dimed or
something like that?
Did you give it thought?
Did you think it would
change the story?
Or why aren't you a
character in the book?
>> Matthew Desmond: I
gave it a ton of thought.
You know, Nickel and Dimed
is a first person because,
like, that's the idea.
Like, I went and I did this.
And I -- it is a form of immersive
journalism, or ethnography,
but it's also -- I didn't
want the reader to look at me.
I didn't want the reader
to care about me.
Like, I am not the
important thing in the story.
Arlene and Crystal and
Vanetta and Scott and Lorraine,
they're the important
people in the story.
And so I didn't want, when something
was happening, you thinking,
"How's Matt dealing with this?"
Or, "Where is Matt in the story?"
I didn't want you to care,
and so I erased myself.
And I write about, like,
the tradeoffs of that kind
of approach in the end of the book.
I'm being told by the bosses
that I have to wrap it up.
Thank you guys so much --
>> Thank you.
>> For coming.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.